[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Anne gellineck guten Abend das
konspirative treffen rechtsextremer
Netzwerker in Potzdam wirkt nach an der
Versammlung letzten November hatten auch
afdptiker und mindestens ein CDU
Mitglied teilgenommen Thema der
Konferenz wie wird man Ausländer und
Deutsche mit Migrationshintergrund los
seit das Treffen bekannt wurde ist die
Diskussion über den mit der AFD neu
entbrannt auch und besonders in der CDU
von deren Vorstandsklausur in Heidelberg
und der Balance zwischen ampelkritik und
Bekämpfung der AFD berichtet matthas
feloff es ist ein äußerst zufriedener
Friedrich märz zum Ende seiner
jahresauftagtklausur geschlossen wie
selten steht die CDU da keine Debatten
über den Kurs oder den
Kandidaten ich Bedau das dass sie keine
Gelegenheiten hatten
zwischendurch Nachrichten abzusetzen
über Streit in der CDU aber da wo kein
Streit ist können Sie leider auch zu
diesem Thema nichts berichten Friedrich
März verpasst seiner Partei mit dieser
Klausur einen neuen Kurs im Umgang mit
der AFD den Kampf aufnehmen die AFD
inhaltlich Stellen in jedem Wahlkampf
und auf jedem Marktplatz sei jetzt die
Aufgabe der CDU schaut bitte genau hin
wen ihr da möglicherweise wählt das ist
keine Partei die dieses Land
wirtschaftlich voranbringt das ist keine
Partei die die Arbeitnehmer in
Deutschland besser ausstattet das ist
eine Partei die nur auf der Basis des
Populismus Ressentiments schirt Auslöser
dieser kehtwende ist eine
geheimkonferenz im letzten November bei
der AFD Politiker unter anderen ein
Vertrauter von Alis Weidel mit
rechtsextremen über eine millionenfache
Vertreibung von Migranten diskutierten
gegen einen pozim ebenfalls anwesendes
CDU Mitglied so berichtet der CDU
Generalsekretär laufe inzwischen ein
Ausschussverfahren
deportationsfantasien in diesen Zeiten
auszuleben habe ich persönlich als sehr
krass empfunden und wieder spricht der
freiheitlichen Grundordnung unseres
Landes im Ziel einig in den Worten oft
unterschiedlich die CDU tastet sich in
die neue Rolle schließlich will man auch
die Ampel ablösen es darf nicht darum
gehen die Opposition als Opposition die
Regierung in Grund und Boden zu reden
aber wir müssen schon deutlich machen wo
die Unterschiede sind und wir müssen
deutlich machen dass diese
ampelregierung für Deutschland keine
gute Politik macht da ist die Tonalität
in den CDU Verbänden im Osten schon
anders härter nicht nur gegen die AFD
der Opfermythos der AFD der muss ein
Ende haben wir machen die nicht zu
metüren diese angebliche alternative
höcke muss ins Licht gezogen werden weil
dann wird nämlich auch seine ganze
Schwäche offenbar die Ampel in Berlin
wirkt als Brandbeschleuniger für den
Protest und für die Sorgen der Menschen
das kommt im Osten noch mal viel härter
an weil die Menschen weniger im portmone
haben und auch in der Debatte um die
Sinnhaftigkeit eines AFD Verbotes gehen
die Stimmen zwischen Ost und West CDU
auseinander aber anders als oft in der
Vergangenheit wird aus unterschiedlichen
Meinungen kein offener
Streit es ist eine rechtsextreme Partei
ich weiß schon dass das sehr sorgsam
vorbereitet sein muss deswegen dürfen
wir da auch keine Schnellschüsse machen
aber eine große Sympathie habe ich auf
jeden Fall dafür das Verfassungsgericht
hat im letzten Verbotsverfahren den Satz
in das Urteil reingeschrieben es kann
den Parteien nicht abnehmen sich um die
Wähler zu bemühen die CDU hat sich heute
vorgenommen diesen Bemühungen um die
Wähler einen neuen Kurs zu verpassen und
dem Buchstaben u für Union eine neue
fast ungewohnte Gemeinsamkeit gleich
mit aus ihrer politischen Agenda machen
die hui im Jemen kein he auf ihrer
Flagge steht Tod Israel Tod Amerika
verdammt sein die Juden die
islamistischen Krieger sind
Überzeugungstäter und betrachten sich
als als Vorkämpfer der palästinensischen
Sache mit Raketen und Drohnen von Iran
hochgerüstet bedrohen sie die
internationale Handelsschiffahrt und die
antwortluftschläge der USA und
Großbritanniens sehen sie gar als
propagandageschenk seht her das große
Amerika ist unser Gegner Dalia anta
berichtet der Flugplatz von hodida im
Jemen vor und nach den Angriffen auf
Stellungen der von Iran unterstützten
huthi Miliz ellitenbilder zeigen das
Ausmaß der
Zerstörung vom Bord des uszerstörers USS
Kani hier Archivbilder ist in der Nacht
zu Samstag laut usmitär eine weitere
Stellung der Rebellen mit
Marschflugkörpern angegriffen worden
Ziel eine
Radaranlage rund 230 km von hodeida die
Hauptstadt Sanaa sie ist unter Kontrolle
der Rebellen das ZDF kann nur unter
Aufsicht drehen was gesagt wird wird
strengstens kontrolliert die die mit
unds sprechen zeigen sich nach dem
erneuten Beschuss der USA
unbeeindruckt das sind brutale Angriffe
aber sie machen uns stärker und
standhafter sie sollten das israelische
Volk Treffen nicht das muslimische aber
wir werden bis zum letzten Tag unseres
Lebens an der Seite von Gaza
stehen das jemeneitische Volk ist an
solche Dinge gewöhnt selbst wenn sie uns
noch mal und noch mal angreifen oder ein
viertes Mal werden wir unsere
Entscheidungen
in der Nacht zum Freitag hatten die USA
und Großbritannien mit Unterstützung
Verbündeter nach pentagonangaben knapp
30 Stellungen der hui Miliz attackiert
der Militärschlag eine Reaktion auf die
Angriffe der Rebellen auf mehr als zwei
Dutzend internationale Handelsschiffe im
Roten
Meer die Miliz selbst veröffentlicht
heute dieses propagandav inszeniert
seinen fanatischen Hass auf die USA und
Israel probtar den über Fall auf eine
israelische Siedlung droht mit
Vergeltung viele Beobachter erwarten
eine weitere
Eskalation und aus Sanaa der Hochburg
der islamistischen huthi Kämpfer ist uns
jetzt unsere Korrespondentin golini ATI
zugeschaltet goline zwei Nächte lang gab
es nun Luftangriffe auf Militäranlagen
der hui welche Reaktionen gibt es in
Sanaa sind die hui eher geschwächt oder
am Ende sogar
gestärkt
also mein Eindruck die westlichen
Luftangriffe waren so etwas wie ein
Ritterschlag für die his sie haben
unglaublich viel an Sympathie in der
Region dazu gewonnen und historisch ist
es so dass jeder Angriff auf die huthis
sie gestärkt hat die Bevölkerung hinter
sie gesammelt hat in den vergangenen
Wochen konnten sie tausende neuer junger
Kämpfer rekrutieren und krieg das ist
für diese Bewegung nicht das letzte
Mittel der Wahl sondern es ist eine Art
Lebensart sie sehen sich als Sieger des
jemenitischen Bürgerkrieges und sie
haben keine Angst vor den USA sie haben
den Rückzug der Amerikaner aus
Afghanistan genauestens studiert noch
eine wichtige Sache last but not least
dieses Thema palästiner das Thema Gaza
nutzen die huis natürlich auch um ihre
eigene Agenda voranzutreiben um ihre
eigene absolute herrschäft zu
zementieren und auch abzulenken von
einer der schlimmsten humanitären Krisen
der hier im Jemen sie sind als einzige
westliche Journalistin in die hoi
Hochburg gereist wie sind ihre
Arbeitsbedingungen wie frei können sie
berichten die Machthaber haben uns heute
zum ersten mal erlaubt unsere Arbeit
hier nachzugehen in Sana die Begegnungen
sind freundlich aber unsere
Bewegungsfreiheit ist schon sehr
eingeschränkt das heißt jedes Bild wird
kontrolliert jedes Wort des einer
unserer Interviewpartner sagt wird
strengstens aufgezeichnet und
kontrolliert trotzdem würde ich sagen es
ist wichtig hier zu sein es ist wichtig
zu verstehen was hier passiert denn
schließlich leben über 80% der Jemeniten
unter der Herrschaft der huis
goline war das aus der jemenitischen
Hauptstadt Sanaa herzlichen Dank
dorthin und das Gespräch haben wir vor
zwei Stunden
aufgezeichnet und wir bleiben beim
naostkonflikt und schauen nach Israel wo
immer noch über 100 Geiseln in der Hand
der Hammers sind die Nachrichten mit
gundol Gause Israels premier netanahu
hat vor dem 100 Kriegstag gegen die
Hamas die Entschlossenheit seines Landes
bekräftigt niemand werde Israel
aufhalten in Tel Aviv erinnern an diesem
Abend Angehörige an die von der Hamas
festgehaltenen Geiseln noch immer sind
mehr als 100 Menschen in ihrer
Gewalt weltweit protestierten heute
gegen die andauernden israelischen
Angriffe im Gazastreifen 10tausende
Menschen unter anderem in London Rom und
Washington wegen einer gescheiterten
Klage gegen die New York Times muss der
frühere US-Präsident Trump der Zeitung
rund 400 000$ Anwaltskosten erstatten
die New York Times hatte 2018 berichtet
dass Trump sein Vermögen nicht selbst
erarbeitet sondern vom Unternehmen
seines Vaters hunderte Millionen Dollar
übertragen bekommen hatte gegen die
Berichterstattung hatte Trump geklagt
und
verloren zu Maß und Mitte hat
Bundeskanzler Scholz in Bezug auf die
bauernproteste aufgerufen Galgen seien
keine Argumente zugleich betonte er
Subventionen könnten nicht auf ewig
bestehen vor der für Montag in Berlin
angekündigten Großdemonstration gab es
auch an diesem Samstag wie hier in
schleswiig-holstein wieder protestak
Aktionen in mehreren Städten haben
jeweils hunderte Menschen gegen die AFD
protestiert in Düsseldorf forderten rund
600 Demonstranten ein Parteiverbot gegen
die AFD zu prüfen und in Duisburg
beteiligten sich an Protesten gegen
einen Neujahrsempfang der AFD mit
Parteichefin Weidel nach Polizeiangaben
2400 Menschen mehreren Medienvertretern
verweigerte die AFD den Zutritt zur
Veranstaltung
es ist eine Wahl im Schatten der
Großmacht Taiwan liegt rund 150 km vom
chinesischen Festland entfernt und ist
zwar de facto unabhängig mit eigenen
Pässen und eigener Währung dennoch
betrachtet China die Insel als Teil der
Volksrepublik Staatschef shijinping
schließt eine gewaltsame
Wiedervereinigung ausdrücklich nicht aus
die Wähler in Taiwan haben sich davon
nicht beeindrucken lassen und den
Kandidaten zum Präsidenten gewählt der
Taiwans Eigenständigkeit gegen China
verteidigen und die Insel aus der
wirtschaftlichen Umklammerung lösen will
Miriam Steimer aus
taip als William lei vor mehr als 30
Jahren zum ersten Mal als Abgeordneter
kandidierte waren seine Haare nach
langen Tagen mit wählerbuchen und reden
oft
unordentlich er fragte ein Haarschnitt
machen der wenig Pflege braucht ich
machte einen Scherz klar ich mach dir
einen
präsidentenhaarschnitt heute wird der
Scherz Wirklichkeit inzwischen ist es
der Sohn des 72-jährigen der immer noch
William le Haare schneidet und nun wird
lei der neue Präsident
Taiwans seine Rede eine Botschaft an
seine Wählerinnen und Wähler aber auch
an
China mit dieser Wahl von der ganzen
beobachtet haben wir allen bewiesen dass
wir zwischen Demokratie und Diktatur auf
der Seite der Demokratie
sind er wird wohl die Linie seiner
Vorgängerin fortsetzen die Volksrepublik
verbal nicht zu offensiv angehen und
sich gleichzeitig auf die Position
zurückziehen dass Taiwan bereits ein
souveränes unabhängiges Land
ist für Peking ist das ein Problem der
Kandidat derö zu China suchte seine
Partei gewinnt jetzt zum dritten Mal
Peking könnte reagieren mit verstärkten
militärmanövern oder weiteren
wirtschaftlichen
Sanktionen denn demokratische Wahlen wie
hier in einem Wahllokal im Tempel sind
ein Problem für den mächtigen Nachbarn
in der Logik von chinas Führung dürfte
es sie gar nicht geben denn sie
betrachtet Taiwan ja als Teil ihres
Staatsgebiets die Mehrheit der
Taiwanesen sieht das
anders Pflicht nichts weiter es ist
meine Pflicht als Bürger ich werde
denjenigen der Frieden bringt ich bin zu
alt für einen Krieg guck dir den
russisch-ukrainischen Krieg an danach
wird nichts mehr übrig sein es wird
keinen Gewinner
geben beim stimmenauszählen kann jeder
zugucken zum achten Mal wähten die
Taiwaner heute ihren Präsidenten stolz
feiern sie ihr demokratisches
Wahlrecht William le Frisur ist übrigens
immer noch der präsidentenschnitt von
vor über 30 Jahren wir nennen ihn
leisschnitt nicht Mittelscheitel sondern
leichnitt und den sollen Kunden in
seinem Friseurladen immer mal wieder
verlangen mehr Hintergrund dazu was die
Wahl von William le für das Verhältnis
zu China bedeutet finden Sie auch online
bei uns auf ZF heute und in unserer App
und jetzt noch mal gundola mit dem
üblichen
samstagssice zunächst die gewinnzahlen
vom Lotto sie lauten ohne Gewehr
16 8 26 27 48 Superzahl 6 weitere
Gewinnzahlen auf Lotto zdf.de und im ZDF
Text auf Seite
556 das Wetter bringt Regen und manche
Orts wieder Glättegefahr viel Sonne gibt
es ganz im Süden sonst wird es meist
stark bewölkt zeitweise regnet oder
schneit es -1 bis +5° am Montag
wechselhaft mit vielen Schnee und
Graupelschauern am Dienstag
vorübergehend Wetterberuhigung Mittwoch
von Südwesten her kräftige Schnee und
Regenfälle -1 bis +
6° und alles vom Sport kommt jetzt im
Aktuellen Sportstudio mit senfoss direkt
danach gibt's eine heute Express tschüss
bis morgen
tschüss